oh we shouldn't shouldn't do in case of
a fire
Thank You members we did everybody
members non-members substitute members
independence thank you for coming out of
beam in to see you see you see right
perhaps soon counselor mr. Eliot Laysan
counsel John Mason is substituting for
him thank you very much John for coming
Kalas let me see there he comfortable
shoes away and mr. P Scott independent
person he's sent apologies are there any
other apologies art or anybody okay
substitute members I've said that
counselors your local Thank You members
attending minutes of the meeting held in
the 16th of November and standard
subcommittee of the 23rd of October 1919
on may 2017 I'm going by the Cubbies is
everybody any problems within a loti can
we have it oh yeah yeah grieve it all
then five declarations of interest
Ellery declarations are very interested
to remember okay and number six this has
to come back to the stainless committee
because to do with development and to be
planning training and we'll read it
I will pass over to Christine if there's
any questions you want to ask with
Christine want to say anything on tip on
it it's not a problem you want to just
give it yeah thank you madam chair me
I'll give it rasuu my and apologies in
advance for my choice which is just
about lasting the objectives that the
working group had was to examine the
training program and to assure that it
was relevant for members needs and to
increase the uptake of the training
firstly I would like to thank the
positively constructing a constructive
heedful of all the members of the
working group and the officers and
especially the helpful observations of
the independent person
I think the group worked exceptionally
well together we have designed the
course to reflect this is the training
course for the next year
- if we reflect both the needs of the
council and to incorporate the subjects
requested by mebiner sophia report we
did a survey those elements not included
and there weren't many nah mostly
officer suggestions and will be
considered for the next training session
together with member requests and
feedback information we have spread out
the training dates to lessen the burden
or members and staff have necessity the
main training sessions are at the
beginning of the municipal year and the
dates the whole year have been decided
on to facilitate planning training
breaks and the length of courses was
also discussed and clarified where
necessary one of the main difference is
the evaluation forms they would no
longer be they are going to be changed I
haven't
completed yet they no longer be handed
to little ol seen by the trainer's they
will be entirely confidential though
there is even there will be two ways of
returning them one with a handbag which
we handed out or there'll be a sealed
box and those comments any people or
whether the trainer's don't see them
they will be used to assess and compile
the next thing I think the problem we
have at the moment is they're handed to
a trainer which obviously isn't
confidential and it includes freedom of
speech so to speak so that's been in
hand and hopefully that will yeah that
knowledge will improve feedback is what
we want is feedback so that we can
develop courses that are more
appropriate the main changes are to the
development training which reflect the
concern expressed by members over course
content and suitability and also reflect
the changing needs of the small smaller
development committee with potentially
more flexible membership we've split as
if you've read the report you see we've
actually split the training into two
separate remember groups but the there
is no real change for new members they
will have to serve the normal training
that we know change for them they will
have to
they cannot miss to the secretary of
training sessions to be eligible where
the change comes is member for existing
members where if you've read the report
I'm sure
please he seems complex but it's not
basically people had two years on
Development Committee in the last six
years and the majority of members have
and a type and but only a certain number
of training sessions then you only have
to take one training session a year it's
up to you we think the members have the
ability to know what training they need
after that level and to go to as many or
as few as appropriate so it's taking the
onus off of if you like they it's making
it more flexible and it's taking the
onus off of more experienced members
bearing in mind that more experienced
members also likely to be more involved
in the administration of the council
that was another recognition the other
change is the appeals situation so we
don't know this sounds awful but I'm
getting there we chairman and I attended
an appeal situation we were tasked with
knowing if the person that was training
had knowledge commensurate with their
penis we had no way of assessing them
and at the time it took up was in order
it took office entirety then I think it
was almost humiliating for the members
that had to attend so it totally changed
that we've got a work done away with
that saved staff time and if members who
don't qualify
your members anyway they can come to
this committee and if they look
Assistant Director of Planning can't
spare the time to go through with them
they will if not they're just about as
they are here for it until the next
training session but to compensate for
that we put in slightly more training
sessions it says for flexibility and
also because they were requested there's
a woman deliberately planning Trinity
was all requested but for weaving
cooperating if there's any questions
I'll take and the period of any two
years after the previous six years for
elected members it could be quite a bit
of regulation if someone then
effectively could have had no training
in or no membership of the development
committee for four years that they would
have had to attend at least one training
session each year sure yeah a she don't
win by any regulatory changes those
years but the reason for the further
allowing that is because we assumed this
and with a more experienced Memphis
before initially wouldn't know it should
know once you've got that basic
understanding if they need to attend a
training session and also we're not
setting up sessions so whether it are
changes they were quick there are in
there I think there's one way we
cooperated so we're there are changes
there are sessions and I think we ought
to respect members ability to a degree
to determine whether they need it it was
slightly different when we had 39 and
Development Committee we don't know this
was a different situation but returning
members well that's if someone's
returned six in a little six years so
very might real acting thurs
someone could be out just for one year
they could have done four years I'm
develop
you know what about that they've been
out for six years they would be treated
as new members it's returning with its
the six years it's two years identify
the last six years so you could be up
for five years and not be treated as a
returning now you'd be able to each
exhumed onto it isn't well I might just
be me and the way I'm reading this it
wasn't that clear to me because
obviously I'm sure we can reword is it
just me does anyone else feel the
intention is that it's the professor we
see returning nervous is the last six
years so people the last six years on
the previous sheets or they so certainly
if someone has been out for five years
now there would be a new member
so it would be two years out of the last
six years
so anyone this I can't think of another
way to put it out on their usage own
Academy our municipal years actually but
we could have a situation could you not
you say we like two-thirds we do that
there are occasions when we have an auto
production when this family changing
whatever government details determine so
the way I was reading this was that you
could get a situation where you had
these rules as such wouldn't apply if
you had a completely new council elected
little be treated new new counselors so
that this it you know the two situations
ones for we've come from experienced
members just for want of a better
definition and we've defined experience
as having served on the development
committee for two years after the
previous six years as an elected member
including members returning to the chaos
of who have in that period perhaps if we
put in that period
clarify that we can do that but it then
goes on to say that members that don't
qualify through exactly the same stay on
there should say yeah thank you
affectations to the Gherkin party
I am I don't know where everybody else
has but I haven't seen the list of the
training of the next year was that
should we have had that we haven't
issued it's alright to learn and I just
wanted I've got off the end of the email
or something is there flexibility is
just picking up your points about new
regulations is there flexibility within
that system but if there is a big new
change from government you know say we
had a change of government and they
wanted to you know a bruising planning
regulations etcetera is there
flexibility is there going to be
flexibility in there to add in
subjecting for everybody yes because
there's always that flexibility and the
reason why we've pushed the training up
sideling it's because we found that one
of the reasons I think the out leg is
slightly less than we'd like is that in
some once you've got three or four yeah
I'll make it fast actually so we have
not pushed it as much as I would like to
say to be honest I'd like to go right
out to meet people but I think we put
has a February up again tonight I don't
take put spread it over which means that
should there be any change
it's quite easy to slice it and we've
got the August we have nothing for its
problem okay that was Jeb that was my
main concern
no it's possible we covered that
of course yeah thank you
it was could we find ourselves in a
situation here where we couldn't have a
development committee meeting when we
meet one early unit means that we're
because we don't have trained members
nervously induction training at the
beginning of the year I said 4sa is a
very wouldn't fit with the first need to
have a development committee meeting
there's always in there it's in this one
as well as always been in the training
the induction training there for new
members emailing in mind yes missing
that before we need a meeting at the end
of month I might even have to take
that's covered we didn't have one last
year because it was known as connection
we did we have I think we do a summer 17
to the my name's really 17th of May 17th
of May is the planning mandatory
planning so that would be for all
members or is certainly on new members
so they can go on the obviously it was
slightly more complicated than that
because it means that you presumably
can't be elected to be on that committee
unless you've had training for my arms
reading no no you could be elected to
any committee you take you don't get the
training after you on the committee
you've gotta log into it or nicest thing
the training himself to us so what will
happen is on the 17th isn't the
induction may not form new members plus
a refresher training for any existing
members that one has retained the
flexibility counted not with the
induction training that's always been
but we've always had an induction
training for new members that we have an
all attended has always been a a
induction training
what we've done is included the fact
that existing members can go to its well
so if you were elected to be on that
committee and then you couldn't attend
that mandatory training
you couldn't then you would then have to
get a substitute for the committee
because you weren't trained
yes correct which is the same as the
situation yeah thank you Jim it's done
just wordplay bath time fun words we
pulled him on Cassie's makes noise I
think there's a no she thinks as well I
think you probably need to redefine what
can you confirm what you mean by
mandatory planning go back for counselor
which is lemony Savior if you have I'm
not reading my favorite wine the billets
are on the phone and so that's what I'm
really drawn messages by the way that's
what we've got real quite reading we
referred to when a members achieve the
requirement even one above they would be
required to attend only any one of the
mandatory planning of training sessions
offered each musical year so that seems
to me to exclude then from qualifying
for the developer control committee if
they attend the refreshing hopefully is
that what was meant by is that I mean
out just of the word I think they said I
think that money to be carried as better
planning as he wins most perhaps we
shouldn't have called your manager
planning because I can't find a
definition for man if you party
it's always been called that another the
names come forward we could just change
its planning training yeah I think would
be better
he chose the inductions and call
mandatory it's just called induction
isn't it well we've changed it to in
touch but terrified that it encompasses
all of them so that they holding there's
customers in London so no kidding they
attend the induction and that counts as
a mandatory yes it does
using this I can find it but what you
brought it
I have rate before not completely in
there by the induction discount through
you sometimes easier when you are part
of the group that puts it together
because you know why you're doing what
you're doing that to reading cold as it
were
it is hard and we have difficulty
wording it and certainly any improvement
on the wording I think we're quite happy
with but I'm trying to say here they
mustered any newly elected councillors
for those CalSTRS native development
community must attend the industry and
every time frame which does excuse me
I think you major it be redefined as a
mandatory one otherwise it doesn't count
as you make a tree training does it well
we've said it's our size well how far is
it this session will be available to all
members as a refresher session and we
qualified as a mandatory session for
members attendance you so that was a
call for three out of three
correctly say
okay yes so it doesn't matter you trying
looks easier than paper oh thank you
yeah I thought you had me married
because I thought he was in there yes I
think so basically your fingers
Development Committee so for three years
a most of us herb because it was a 39
yeah committee after some time for was
attending that came out of tree whether
or not they were new so if someone like
yourself or myself put a thing on there
for one we only have to go to work but I
don't think I would potentially choose
to go through a refresher training but
if I wanted to if I've had in a year
nice done like this my two I do think we
need to give members the respect that
they know what training they need rather
than forcing them to sit through
something and that was one of the things
some of the thinking behind what we've
done but I have got a very good this is
the latest if I took a better arm in
this it you think you can do training
whatever we're gonna call it session is
that critical then members need to know
sensible when there is so that they can
eventually once agreed release people to
start sending this out that's what well
it will only apply to new members new
elected members and they've had that all
the time it's always been the same
you've never been learned as a new
counselor to go into planning into
you've done induction training does that
Christian
[Music]
some of us have remained as substitutes
and continued with the training just in
case but a phony for example had to be
called to the committee once we don't
we're not treated me differently to
those so experienced development
committee members know because you've
served over two years and the last six
years
so you're experienced so therefore
because you've served for two years
within your class this experience I
think there's a limit to how detailed we
can get I'll just pick on something what
he was saying it was a second question
okay akhenaten up to me some slightly
different one can only get half before
spins it built far foreign but I've got
the gist of it I cannot situation very
quickly do the basic training the last
day you've got Thursday 29 for 30 2019
what counts miss Islam be the same if
you're not if you're an experienced
counselor but you're a substitute for
the on the Development Committee and
you're not cold for two years
does that count there for us as that
you've not served on it and you've got
to start again if it's refutable
yourself equipment substitutes on
anything they aren't set what happens is
is if someone needs a substitute then
choose someone from their group
substitute first all the same person
said that wouldn't count all right that
we got qualified so substituting one
corner right it would be much too
complex you didn't say how many times it
have substituted I was just thinking
that they would lose you know if you
have been on
because I think this really mainly
applies to the Development Committee
doesn't it if you've not served on the
do if you've not been to a development
committee meeting for over two years
then things might have changed or they
would have had to attend a delicious or
anything I think is cancerous places
finally we've got to get the respect of
each council so those who were they what
to do to trainee otherwise I think that
they'd be silly endeavor to do in front
of a planning session and also the color
contains questions that they don't know
the answers to so I don't think there's
I mean we're not silly we could know
what realize their training and our
training is we need so I'll sure it's
not that complicated
the chair was right we had very lengthy
and complex debate and it was also
obviously in full and it took it really
we've come in at with one page they
started it a lot longer than that and it
was about more complex what we've tried
to do is to keep the standard of
training high at the same time as
respecting members ability to determine
the need that they want Casbah mr. mace
thank you I think you've got to bear in
mind they're not everything is covered
in training and it could never be those
of us have been on development committee
for a very very long time we'll remember
that you receive a very detailed report
and you have the opportunity to ask
questions of officers before the meeting
we often have addendums and you can ask
questions of the officers before the
meeting and officers give us a very
detailed briefing anyway and if there
was something that hadn't been covered
in training but was fairly unique then
we get a pretty detailed briefing so
that the members of the committee could
make an appropriate decision in a
quasi-judicial setting so I'm fairly
content that there wouldn't be a
position where
you could find a development committee
sitting where there was a lack of
training I really believe is no more
questions I'd like to I just want to
clarify when we're referring to the
Ignite and one we and have attended six
or more training sessions that's not
annually so they could have attended
very good day when you a new member yes
you take one you have to turn your on
and you can't miss two consecutive which
is always been the case and causes a lot
of confusion because it grows over the
municipal here but someone she must have
attended six it would normally take you
two years but actually in this one I
think we've got four hundred three one
two three five so you could almost quite
fine again but you still have to do the
two years on planning so it actually
makes it easier but in the last part in
and have intended six or more trans
issues doesn't matter they don't have to
be each year they could have just been
three money or through in another year I
just want to clarify that right yes
because sometimes and that the subject
is repeated misunderstand
right spacings as the committee resolves
seven items on his agenda
are we all in favor I'm sure I can be
chairman because during the discussions
they were changes made
yes it was
yeah the experiment will be defined as
having served there was in that year was
there not someone exactly once having
served on the development committee for
two years out of the previous six years
as a real active member and clearly
movement members returning to the
council in that period yet who have
preferred previous tournament committee
trainee experience thank you the other
one was Robin thank you I think we can't
I think that's already gone as a print
isn't it what they drop you into the
mandatory virtual planetary Hey you mean
that the brochure the browser should
haven't had the brochure done okay so
we're just so basic they would get a job
the term annual trip number two in all
of them if you can't feel free in summer
at work people have to be in everything
let me just have a little three then if
you take mandatory
[Music]
any one of the planning training no
that's fine just say the word manager
yet I think you never turn general will
do it practically and everything where
it is and try and capture it all this
time yeah
because one or two big documents with it
on the only one that would be mandatory
would be the first one for remembers
base not mentally planning system it's
just a plan C there's a mandatory for
Newton because so planning this training
session that's mandatory for new
planning Memphis thank you thank you can
service and I'm having trouble getting
together private general are you moving
it members
let me show you call that any other
changes members we're going to be going
that members doing
have you ever lose placing yet present
you're happy with that yes yes agree
like that unanimous for those only
changes yeah yes just wanna make sure
there is you know no disagreement that's
one yep thank you very much yes just do
it justice like we're gonna revisit in
six months see and it's going so
I think you told with your help I think
this very confidential